INTERVIEWER: So
Robert Anton Wilson
talks about cultural
reality tunnels, all right?
So think of that metaphor.
Think of that image.
Think of a tunnel
of reality, right,
a single worldview, a single
way of seeing things, right?
And it's the only
reality you know,
because you live within
your reality tunnel.
But when you're exposed to
new people, to new ideas,
to different ways
of interpreting
the world, different myths,
different customs, right,
all of these
things-- what they do
is-- unhinge you from
the rigidity of the world
you were born into, giving you
what's akin to an aerial view.
And it's a wonderful
experience, because there's
so much insight to be
gained from that change
in perspective, something
I often converse with you.
Don't you think, Issac?
SUBJECT: Because I
wasn't listening to you.
No, I'm serious.
I'm serious.
INTERVIEWER: He
wasn't even listening.
You see, he was in his
own reality tunnel.
No, what I was saying
is the importance
of going and exploring
new lands, right?
Visiting new places, exposing
yourself to be unfamiliar,
right, the idea that the
unexamined life is not
worth living and how important
it is to do, that every day,
to that practice, to not kind
of take things for granted, so
to speak, to partake in
a dialectical pattern
of reconcilable
estrangement with the world
of everyday perception, as
David Linson talks about.
This idea of
archetypalizing experience,
italicizing experience.
You know, witnessing
the specific,
but beholding it
as the universal.
Everything stands more
clearly for all of its class.
This particular path
becomes the path.
My particular life
becomes the life.
We mythologize ourselves,
and we mythologize the world
in order to enter a
kind of garden of Eden
where we can extract Meaning
from our experiences, patterns
from our experiences.
So that life is not just
mush, but instead, of a movie,
a journey, a motif.
A dream.
A Dream dream within a dream.
Row, row, row, your boat
gently down the stream.
Merrily, merrily, merrily,
merrily life is but a dream.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Anything to
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] with?
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
--when you used to play the
Street Fighter video game,
didn't you go into that world?
Didn't you enter that ontology?
SUBJECT: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
OK, everybody in their own trip.
Catch you guys later.